هذه المره نحن امام انجاز تاريخيا مختلف
بكل المقاييس كان دائما يتم تصويف ان اقوى
المشاركات المغربيه كانت عام 86 ولكن
التاريخ سيعدل نفسه سريعا اليوم ليسجل هذا
الانجاز للمغرب كافضل اداء للمنتخب
المغربي في تاريخ بطوله كاس العالم تنضم
الى الاجواء في الدوحه وينضم الينا زميلي
ليث بازاري اهلا بك ليث معنا على شاشه
العربيه فرحه عامه الان في الدوحه انقل
لناصر
نعم رشا من هنا من امام ملعب المدينه
التعليميه اديوكيشن سيتي ترشح او تدخل
المغرب في الدور في الدور الربع النهائي
لكاس العالم هنا في قطر حتى هذه اللحظه
شاهدنا بعد المشجعين الذين خرجوا من هذا
ستاد من هذا الملعب ملعب المدينه
التعليميه ولكن في الطريق للوصول الى خارج
الملعب يعني نحن على الوقت تماما همم انت
مغربي صح شو رايك بالنتيجه شو رايك
ومبروك للمغرب يعني فرصه جيده لانه من
زمان ما فازوا في كاس العالم
المنتخب المغربي وشرف شرف شرف العرب وشرف
الكره الافريقيه وشمال افريقيا كلها احنا
كنقول له البرازيل احنا قادمون ان شاء
الله وسنفوز بالكاس لان الكاس تنظم في
دوله عربيه
وكالعملنا السعوديه وتونس ويتاهلوا معنا
ولكن حتى ما وفقهمش فتحيه السعوديه وتحيه
لتونس احنا كانقولوا احنا كان نكلوكم
باحسن تمثيل والكاس العرب في الدول
العربيه ستبقى في العرب وهذا وعد المغربي
حر ان شاء الله وعاش الدوله الملكيه وعاش
الملكيه انا وعاش الامراء اليوم
انا توقعاتي كانت اسبانيا بتفوز لانها في
قويه قويه فيها
قوي كمان لكن
اسبانيا قوي شوي وكنت اشجع يعني اشجع
متوتر يعني ممكن لما مجال وقت الزيت 30
دقيقه كنت متوتر كثير لانه صفر صفر
بهذا النصر الذي حقق المنتخب المغربي
احتفل في اني ان اروح همم استعرضوا يعني
اروح ولزقوا واقف يعني اجيبه معي علم
المغرب ان شاء الله سوق واقف على كل حال
رشا انا متاكد سيكون واقفا طول الليل هذه
الليله جميع الذين سيغادرون هذا الملعب
44,652 مشجع ومتفرج هنا سوف ينطلقون الى
هذه المنطقه عادا عن الذين يشجعون من
المناطق اخرى هنا في الدوحه سوف ينطلقون
الى سوق واقف الذي لم يتوقف انا متاكد عن
الاحتفالات طول هذه الليله تفضل الحمد لله
شوف احنا فرحانين اليوم كان عندنا ثقه في
المدرب ديالنا وثيقه في اللاعبين ديالنا
ولماذا ان شاء الله غنمرون ان شاء الله
النصف النهائي
ان شاء الله
اول حاجه شكرا
اشكرهم واحد بواحد لان وقفه مع المنتخب
معنا والدول العربيه الله يجمعنا كيف ما
جمعنا هنا في خطر الله يجمعنا باذن الله
كل ايد واحده مالك مع مالك ورئيس مع رئيس
مشكولوا واحد القوه وهنتصروا باذن الله
والوقت الحالي اللي جمعنا قطر وشيخ تميم
حنين سامع ان شاء الله في الدول العربيه
وشكرا لجميع وشكرا للاذاعه العربيه
[تصفيق]
علي علي علي
عليقه لم تتوقف قبل قبل المباراه ولكن
الذي يحدث هم منفعلون كثيرا مع الذي حدث
حدث هنا في هذا الملعب خلفي الكثير هون
طبعا
لمنتخب المغرب
الى اخر دقيقه وقلنا الحمد لله اللهم اخي
فرحتنا وان شاء الله المباراه الثانيه راح
يكونوا العرب كلهم مبسوطين ان شاء الله شو
اكثر شيء
استاد شو اكثر شيء بين الانواع التشجيع
للمنتخب المغربي والله في
يعني من اول دقيقه واحنا واقفين الى اخر
دقيقه حتى الاخر اخر ضربه كوره اشرف حكيمي
سدد الهدف ما في ولا دقيقه واحده ركزنا
على احد يشجي كنا بنشجع ارجوك
والحمد لله ما راح على الفاضي ودائما
المغرب ان شاء الله